let's cover polymorphism you should
already have a good understanding of
inheritance before you dive into
polymorphism we're gonna cover what is
polymorphism characteristics of
polymorphism types of polymorphism
compile time versus run time
polymorphism super keyword which should
look familiar because it's very similar
in use but now we're looking at the
polymorphism side of it
advantages of polymorphism and the
disadvantages of polymorphism what is
polymorphism
according to chemistry the term
polymorphism can be defined as the
ability of any element or compound to
exist in multiple crystalline forms this
is called polymorphism for example if
you have the carbon atom you can come
out in different forms in coal graphite
and diamond
what is polymorphism in Java similarly
in the terms of Java programming
language polymorphism is defined as the
ability of any object in class in a
class to perform a particular task in
multiple methods this is known as
polymorphism in Java we're gonna open up
our Eclipse editor and we're gonna do
some animal sounds with cows cats and
dogs just kind of a fun almost kids like
example of polymorphism and you can see
I already have my inheritance in here
let's go ahead and create a new package
and we'll call this polymorphism just to
keep it simple
and once we have our polymorphism in
there we're going to go ahead and add a
class in and if you were doing an
abstract class we can lillas abstracts
we're not going to directly access it
and we'll call it animal sounds maybe we
will we'll see how we load the program
app but we'll call this animal sounds
and let's create a public it's not gonna
return anything but we'll call it sound
on here and we just want to go ahead and
have it do a system.out.print and with
our system out print line we'll just
have it say animals make different
sounds there we go so you know it's
really straight simple and
straightforward we're just gonna have it
print something out and if we're gonna
do that let's say I did just a good
thing I didn't make it
abstract let's go ahead and just test it
out and see what it looks like and we'll
do I will call it animal main animal
main and in here let's go ahead and test
out what we just put together we'll do
our static void main so it's going to
run on here
and we'll create our animal sounds we'll
call it animal we don't know what kind
of animal this is we call it new animal
sounds and we'll just take that animal
and I like to put it in capitalized but
usually back to this lower case there we
go and we'll just have our animal dot
sound and let's go ahead and run this
and see what comes out we can see here
animals make different sounds okay
that's not too exciting so let's jump in
there and let's say we have in this case
we're gonna add in a couple of different
animals we'll add in a let's start with
a cow you know why not a cow so we'll
have our cow in here we'll go ahead and
click OK
and now we have our cow class but a cow
doesn't just it makes different noises
but it actually makes us you know a very
clear noise so we'll go ahead and give
the cow a sound and we'll have the cow
say Moo Moo and the cow is going to
extend there's our and we'll put in our
extends animal sounds and then I want to
go back here to our animal mane and now
we have a class cow so in our animal
mane
we want to do cow cow equals new cow
and once we've created the new cow we
also need to go ahead and have the cow
sounds there we go and we run this you
can see it comes out here and says the
cow says Moo Moo so if we go back to cow
we're just going to do this real quick
and let's say we just take this out of
here the public void sound and then
we're going to go into our animal mane
and run that recompiles animals make
different sounds because it doesn't know
what sound a cow makes so this is really
central to polymorphism as we're taking
something going on in the in one setup
that we've brought in and extended from
our animal sounds and we've changed it
to the cow says Moo Moo and we can also
add in multiple animals in here look go
ahead and just add in one more animal
we'll call this one we'll do a dog why
not so here comes in our dog and of
course we want the dog to actually say
something and we'll have the dog go
bow-wow and then we'll go back to our
animal mane we have to create a dog and
we'll say a cow simply dog dog uppercase
for the class lowercase for the actual
object and then of course we need the
dog to make a sound so we'll go down
here and go dog dot sound and when we
run this as you expect the it's gonna
compile it there we go
animals make a different sounds a cow
says Moo Moo the dog says bow-wow
characteristics of polymorphism
the functionality of a method behaves
differently in different situations the
behavior method is dependent on the data
polymorphism is mainly used to implement
inheritance as we saw we did the extends
with the animal sounds polymorphism is
mainly used to implement inheritance it
allows same name for a member of method
in a class with different types which
we'll cover briefly in a minute
polymorphism supports implicit type
conversion
types of polymorphism there are
basically two types of polymorphism that
can be occurred in Java programming
language they are mentioned as follows
compile-time polymorphism runtime
polymorphism compile time polymorphism
gets executed during the compilation
stage here the overloading method gets
resolved in compilation stage so when
you saw me run those in eclipse and it
went through the compile time that's
looking at all the different changes we
made to those classes that's what we're
talking about here is during compile
time in method overloading in Java the
process of method overloading is
achieved when a class has two or more
methods with same name but the specific
method is selected based on the number
of parameters declared will now execute
a program based on the functionality of
additional operator in a different
situation and this flip back gun over to
our Eclipse so in here I'm gonna go back
under the dog and let me just highlight
this and we're gonna do the same thing
so you see right here it says public
void sounds so this is identical public
void sound but instead of sending
nothing we're gonna send it a string
we're gonna call it angry now at this
point you should note that what if it's
a happy dog I would have to add and if
then if the string angry said happy
then we print happy or something else
but we're just keeping it simple so
we've entered another sound identical to
the first but we've added string angry
to it and this is gonna print out the
dog says growl growl now if we go back
to our animal main and here's our dog
same dog same sound but now we're gonna
add a string in here and we put that
string in here we'll go ahead and just
call it angry it doesn't really matter
what string you put in here because we
haven't sorted out what the string means
for now it just as growl growl it's
gonna recompile it so remember this is a
polymorphism during compile time and
here we have it the dog says growl
growls the duck says bow-wow and then
the angry dog says growl growl so there
is another thing called operator
overloading operator overloading is not
supported in Java
authors of Java wanted to keep the
language less complicated explaining
operator overloading it basically is a
way of bundling operations into the call
statement and user procedures it's so
that it looks like a math on a paper you
have a plus ad b plus c kind of thing
and it's all wrapped up in your call to
another statement this just gets
confusing it really isn't necessary so
the driver developers decided not to put
it in there so runtime polymorphism in
java programming language runtime
polymorphism gets handled during the
program execution stage here the
overwriting method gets resolved in
execution so far we've talked about
compile time polymorphism as you saw in
the program we just wrote when it's
compiling it does the extend and figures
out which overload method to use on
there in runtime polymorphism method
overriding in java the method overriding
is a procedure where child class is
allowed to implement a specific class
that is already provided in the parent
class for runtime compilation code or
polymorphism we need to go introduce the
super keyword now from inheritance you
should remember that we can look at
super from before but we're gonna use it
slightly different it's kind of doing
the same thing as when we did the
inheritance but we're doing like what
they call an override during runtime so
the term super is predefined keyword in
Java that is used to refer the immediate
parent class object or method defined in
the program in this procedure whenever
you create an instance of subclass then
automatically an instance of parent
class is also created that will be
implicitly referred by the super
reference variable so going back into
our animal sounds let's go in here to
dog and if we add a super dot sound in
here this is going to reference whatever
our extend is because we extends the dog
extends animal sounds and so here's our
super sound and if we go ahead and both
run and compile this and you can see
here that it comes down and says the dog
says growl growl because that's what we
had it system.out.print line two and
then the super animals make different
sounds and so if we go back to our
animal
this is what it's calling right here is
going back into sound under the animal
mains and it's printing out or doing
whatever it does here at this point we
usually have it returned something so
you can look up whatever the original
class was using so getting back to these
two setups whether you're using the
super to use a runtime polymorphism
because that's what's happening during
runtime versus compile time polymorphism
during compile time polymorphism method
call is handled by the compiler itself
so the program maybe take them second
more to compile but it runs faster in
the runtime the method call cannot be
handled by compiler in the execution
stage so if you have any errors is not
going to show up either during the
compile time we have compiled time
polymorphism is less flexible as it
needs handle all method calls in compile
time so you really in runtime
polymorphism your exhibits higher
flexibility as a method call gets
handled at runtime coming in the
execution period for compile time
polymorphism is less that's what I was
just talking about it compiles it so the
compiling takes maybe a little bit more
but if you're executing the same program
over and over and over again once it's
distributed it's gonna run faster then
of course with the runtime polymorphism
the execution period for runtime
polymorphism takes longer this is a
little bit more usually in most programs
you don't notice this but if you're
executing the same script a thousand
times suddenly that point oh one second
is a lot more it suddenly is adding up a
second each time it goes through the
thousand iterations then with the
compile time polymorphism integrating
the right method call with the right
method is done in compile time and of
course in run time integrating the right
method call with the right method is
done in run time again that's another
delay because it has to figure out what
it's doing it's not already pre mapped
out and finally compile time
polymorphism occurs during method
overloading and operator overloading
where runtime polymorphism occurs during
the method overriding advantages of
polymorphism programmers code can be
reused via polymorphism number one goal
of a programmer is to reuse the code as
much as possible so you're not
reinventing the wheel over and over
again
polymorphism supports single variable
name for multiple data types reduces
coupling between different
functionalities and some of the
disadvantages of polymorphism that can
come up is that polymorphism ends up
raising performance issues in real time
you can see where as you're loading all
these different things you might end up
creating loops you didn't know you're
doing polymorphism reduces readability
of the code sometimes your actual code
everything you look at in Java is
polymorphism all based on a primary
object so you could have a very
complicated set up and then it actually
is very easy to read when you actually
put your final variable in there but
when you're going through lines and
lines of code it can be really hard to
figure out what's going on as you loop
through all these different inherited
modules our classes programmers find
polymorphism difficult to implement just
depends the more you use it the easier
it is thank you for joining us for more
information please visit